[Música]
não existem índios no brasil existem
povos com suas imunidades e
espiritualidades tradições línguas e
nomes próprios povos que já estavam aqui
quando os invasores europeu chegaram
povos que já habitavam aqui antes de
todas essas terras serem chamadas de
brasil
o brasil é terra indígena por isso é a
esses povos podemos chamá-los de
inativos ou indígenas que quer dizer
originário de um lugar
a unesco assinala 350 fininhas e 274
línguas indígenas no brasil
eu não sou mais um número e eu não sou
índia
eu sou macuxi eu me chamo júri do rico e
sou descendente do povo mapuche
se hoje eu me apresento com muito
orgulho da minha descendência durante 26
anos não foi assim
a literatura indígena me ajudou a
encontrar o meu caminho de volta para
casa
no ano de 2017 eu assistir uma palestra
do escritor daniel munduruku daniel
munduruku é um dos maiores expoentes da
literatura indígena naquela noite ele
falou sobre a importância de resgatar
mos a nossa ancestralidade e aquela
mensagem me interpelou a buscar a minha
eu tinha 27 anos e eu sabia que a minha
existência não era reduzida a cabocla
nem a descendência de meu pai que é
peruano nem a de minha mãe que a
guianense eu sabia que tinha mais o
segundo encontro foi com o escritor
cacau irá que veio palestrar aqui em
porto alegre e ele falou sobre o
xamanismo guarani ea importância de nos
conectarmos com os mais velhos uma
prática perdida na sociedade nacional e
pensando nisso eu mandei uma mensagem
pra minha mãe é uma mensagem bem
despretensiosa e perguntei se nós
pretendíamos de algum povo se ela de 100
dias e meu pai de cem dias de algum povo
já que na nossa família sempre foi muito
exaltado o fato da minha mãe na cena
guiana que é um país de língua inglesa e
o meu pai ser descendente também dos
peruanos dos espanhóis no caso né ea
minha mãe respondeu na mensagem a tua
bisavó clarinda é uma coxinha
eu confesso para vocês que eu não sei
dizer o que eu senti naquele momento mas
eu posso dizer que o meu coração se
acendeu
como descendente indígena eu descobri
que havia muito mais além dos adjetivos
ruim dos estereótipos lançados à cultura
nacional e repetidos à exaustão em
livros didáticos romances teatros museus
em todos os cantos
eu comecei a descobrir outros mundos
eu descobri um os mundos que não me
contavam eu descobrir o mundo dos avós
o mundo das avós o mundo das histórias
antigas sagradas
eu descobri o mundo das rodas de
fogueira dos humanos e não humanos das
ervas medicinais e aos poucos eu nem
percebi eu fui tomando consciência de
que eu era só filha dessa mãe terra
mas todos os estereótipos os apelidos os
xingamentos que eu como indígena vivi e
vivo tem uma história e eu vou contar
ela pra vocês
quando o colonizador europeu chegou aqui
invadiu as nossas terras
ele já não sabia mais sonhar por isso os
corpos indígenas sentiram o peso do
chumbo à dor das armas biológicas como a
gripe a varíola a sífilis
o ventre das mulheres indígenas foram
duramente violados e todos homens e
mulheres sentiram a catequese atravessar
suas almas como uma flecha envenenada
matando seus ritos cantos e tradições
mas não morremos por isso eu digo que os
povos indígenas são sobreviventes e
seguem lutando de todos os modos lutam
contra a figura histórica de preguiçosos
mas a história oficial quase não lembra
que os povos indígenas foram explorados
nas coletas das drogas do sertão e de
tão explorados que foram morriam para
sobreviver precisavam fugir para dentro
das matas e lutar por suas vidas
isso é história oficial quase não conta
lutam contra a figura histórica de bom
selvagem do bom selvagem mas a
literatura indigenista não conta que o
indígena representado na literatura é
aquele indígena já está terminado ou
considerado assimilado e que o selvagem
feroz e racional é aquele que luta pela
sua vida e por seus territórios
isso josé de alencar não conta luta
ainda contra a figura histórica de 6 do
passado desde o império até a década de
a sociedade nacional acredita as
políticas indigenistas acreditavam que o
sujeito indígena era primitivo que aos
poucos ele evoluir ia e ser integrada à
sociedade envolvente e seria brasileiro
havia essa crença de que se ele
aprendesse a língua portuguesa se
convertessem ao cristianismo aprendesse
as habilidades técnicas e usasse das
tecnologias como o celular a cartão de
crédito ele se ele esqueceria as suas
crenças que seria sua língua e
esqueceria suas tradições mas o sábio
marcos terena que tem uma famosa frase
que diz posso ser tudo aquilo que você é
sem deixar de ser quem sou
provou que ser aviador não tirou dele o
orgulho do pertencimento étnico e ele
continuou e continua sendo terena mário
juruna
foi deputado federal sem deixar de ser
xavante
joênia wapixana é hoje deputada federal
e luta
pelo direito dos seus povos e o direito
dos povos indígenas do brasil
pertencimento étnico é um sentimento de
amor que nasce com você permanece e não
desaparece nem depois que você morre
porque ele sobrevive na memória coletiva
do nosso povo e por fim os povos
indígenas lutam contra a figura de povos
agrafos que quer dizer povos em
literatura mas ninguém fala que os povos
indígenas são tradicionalmentes técnicos
eles cantam eles dançam eles pintam eles
desculpem eles contam muitas histórias e
o que é a literatura se não uma boa
história contada a literatura indígena
então ela é anterior a essa escrita
alfabética mas de tantos equívocos
contado e repetidos na sociedade
nacional
o sujeito indígenas resolveram adotar a
escrita alfabética publica seus livros
autorais e contar as suas vivências do
outro lado da história e da literatura
o levantamento bibliográfico coordenado
pelo daniel munduruku mostrou o número
de 44 escritores indígenas no brasil
desses 44 11 são mulheres
desse contingente são vinte e dois povos
que passam a publicar a estar presente
em livrarias estantes virtuais
bibliotecas de escolas são vinte e dois
povos que começam a estabelecer um
diálogo com a sociedade nacional
tem muito tem muita poesia tem muita
contação de história tem muita prosa
então podemos dizer que em cada livro
conhecemos um autor e o seu povo por
exemplo daniel assina como mundurucu
ailton assina como krenak aurita assina
como tabajara e em cada um desses livros
passamos a conhecer suas histórias na
ces traz seus ritos seus costumes suas
línguas maternas e as suas mensagens o
que eles têm a nos dizer
então podemos dizer que cada livro é uma
aldeia recentemente lendo um texto da
sua mikati nesses dias na verdade a esse
texto me marcou profundamente porque ele
fala do amor sobre a mãe terra e da
necessidade de recuperarmos esse
sentimento
suas palavras ancestrais nos diz que nós
somos só filhos
nós somos os filhos do tempo do vento e
do anoitecer
sentimos a dor de pestanas arrancadas
atolamos em mangue para pegar caranguejo
levamos surra de urtiga
dormimos em rede ou esteira e mesmo que
ainda cansados
esperamos diariamente à noite que traz
os gritos do mar para uma lua brilhante
ainda que andemos longe nunca iremos
esquecer disso
falamos com o passarinho comemos beijo
com carne de caça corremos de raposa
parida vemos a morte se enroscar em
nossos pés sob a forma da cobra grande
nadamos em lagoa encantada somos curados
com fumaça
nós somos filhos do ar nós somos filhos
da água da mata e do entardecer
vemos a vida com a visão dos que nascem
no meio das pedras tendo a palha do
ouricuri como ninho para ser visto tem
que ser tingido de negro e desta forma
nossa gente obtém o direito de pertencer
o sangue de nossos antepassados a do boa
nossa terra fez mais seguro com que
quando a pintado em nosso corpo deixa
nosso espírito livre para voar sobre a
terra encantada
dançar ao redor da fogueira sagrada das
festas do nosso povo que com o sorriso
de prata ilumina mata inteira e nos traz
o amanhecer
nós somos filhos do fogo
e sabemos que o melhor de tudo isso é
que nós somos só filhos
é chegada a hora de conhecer a palavra
dos chefes indígenas é chegada a hora de
reconhecer que seus modos de vida
tradicionais mantém em suspense o céu
evitando que ele desabe sobre as nossas
cabeças salvando a humanidade indígena e
não indígena todos nós merecemos um rio
sem dejetos de minérios todos nós
merecemos um solo que produz alimentos
sem venenos todos nós merecemos um ar
limpo sem doenças de fumaças que cubram
o céu durante o dia e todos nós
merecemos viver bem nessa grande maloca
que é o mundo
então eu insisto não existem índios no
brasil existem povos com suas
humanidades espiritualidades tradições
línguas e nomes próprios e eu sei que se
passarmos a conhecer os nossos povos
passaremos a nomeá los do jeito certo e
passaremos a amar a terra como ela nos
ama porque essa é a lição que os povos
indígenas nos ensino
daniel munduruku ailton é krenak sua
mikati é potiguar a eu julho do rico sou
uma koch e o meu convite é para que
conheçamos cada um desses brasília a
causa indígena não é só minha a causa
indígena é de todos nós
[Aplausos]